[MUSIC PLAYING]
[CICADAS]
I want to ask you what part
of the country you come from.
I originate from Canada.
Now, guess where that is.
I know where Canada is.
I've been there myself.
Well-traveled for a slave.
Solomon Northup is an
excellent player on the violin.
I was born a free man, lived
with my family in New York.
Be good for you ma.
Until the day I was deceived--
To Solomon.
--kidnapped, sold into slavery.
Well, boy, how you feel now?
My name is Solomon Northup.
I'm a free man, and you have no
right whatsoever to detain me.
You no free man.
You're nothing but
a Georgia runaway.
[MUSIC - TOPSY CHAPMAN, "ROLL
JORDAN ROLL"]
(SINGING) Went down
to the river Jordan.
And that servant--
Who don't obey his lord--
--shall be beaten
with many strikes.
That's scripture.
The condition of your
laborers, it's all wrong.
They're my property.
You say that with pride.
I say it is fact.
Snake!
Man does how he pleases
with his property.
Who?
You come here.
I said come here.
Days ago, I was with
my family, in my home.
Now you tell me all is lost.
If you want to survive, do
and say as little as possible.
(SINGING) My soul
arise in heaven, Lord.
Well, I don't want to survive.
(SINGING) For the
year when Jordan roll.
I want to live.
I thought you knowed something.
I did as instructed.
There's something wrong, it's
wrong with the instruction.
Master brought you here to work.
Anymore will earn
you 100 lashes.
I know what it's like to be
the object of Master's lashes.
In his own time, could
learn to manage them all.
I will survive.
I will not fall into despair.
I will keep myself hardy
till freedom is opportune.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I was a free man.
I'm not a slave.
Hello, everyone, and welcome.
My name is Steve McQueen.
I'm a director,
writer, producer.
And I'm here to talk to an
amazing individual, an artist,
a cinematographer, Sean Bobbitt.
Hello, Sean.
How are you?
Hi, Steve.
Always great to see you.
Good, good, good.
I've just seen your last film,
Judas and the Black Messiah,
that you shot.
It's extraordinary.
I just want to ask you--
the first question,
really, is, how is it--
how do you begin to
collaborate with a director?
What is your first process?
00:03:01,610 --> 00:03:07,670
The process of collaboration is
actually what it's all about.
The job of the
cinematographer is
to interpret the
ideas of the director
and put them on a screen.
So the first thing that you
need to do when you first
meet a director on
a project is, first
of all, determine whether you
want to work with them or not.
And this is-- the answer to that
is yes, then you kind of need
to determine what your
role is with the master
cinematographer.
Directors are all
individually unique,
and they all have their
own means of communication,
their own ideas.
And some of them
are very, very good
at getting those
ideas across, in terms
of their understanding
of the film and the story
and the real depth of the tale
that they're trying to tell.
And some of them are very,
very powerfully visual.
And they have worked on
this project for years,
whereas I come in off
the street, literally.
And some of them,
the visual power
means that my role is
slightly different.
If they have strong ideas,
then all I have to do
is listen to those
ideas very carefully
and try to ensure
that those ideas are
what are incorporated into
the visual look of the film.
Some directors are not
so strong visually.
Their interests are
more in performance,
are more in
storytelling, and less
to do with the actual frame.
And for those people,
then it's my job
to start to suggest
ideas, to put things
forward as to what the visual
approach of the film might be.
And so all the time, you're
trying to develop a dialogue,
and, from that dialogue, discern
you know what this film is
and what it means,
and then try to--
between the collaboration
of the two of you,
and also with all
the other heads
of departments, particularly the
production designer, costume,
hair and makeup, and
sound, working all together
to try and make those
ideas real and to put them
on a screen in a coherent
way that effectively
tells the story.
What is the most
challenging aspect
of being a cinematographer?
Is there something that you meet
every time you go on a shoot?
Or is there something which
sort of you know is coming
and you have to overcome
it, or something like that?
What is the most challenging
aspect of doing your job?
Well, it's an odd
job in many ways,
because the actual
description is very broad.
A cinematographer, it's not
just about pointing a camera
at someone and
turning a light on.
The side of it that is always
unknown is sort of the--
really, it's management
and logistics.
Yes.
Because you-- a film
runs on momentum.
And you don't want
to be the person who
is slowing down that momentum.
So you have to be prepared
and you have to be planned.
And you have to be ready
for just about anything that
might happen.
And I have to say, the most
exciting things that I really
enjoy on a shoot are when
the unexpected does happen.
I was about to ask
you about that.
How do you deal with that?
I think your background
is a documentary film
cameraman is sort
of, I think, one
of your jewels in
your crown, really.
Yeah.
Coming from the world
of documentaries,
where you don't have a
script, where there's
no linear narrative, that as
you're working on a project,
it's happening in front of
you, and you have to respond
in real time, when
you're working in drama
you have a script.
You know what's
supposed to happen.
And so you can plan accordingly.
But at the same time,
one thing that I've
learned over the years, and
particularly working with you,
Steve, is to expect
the unexpected,
and to look forward
to the unexpected,
and to embrace the unexpected.
Embrace the unexpected, exactly.
Because it's in those
things that you could never
imagine happening that there's
little moments of magic.
At what point-- I mean,
imagine all the people
who are interested in
being a cinematographer.
At what point were
you comfortable?
At what point-- how long did it
take you to get to that moment,
or if you ever got to that
moment, where you are on set,
and there's a certain
understanding or--
I won't even say confidence.
I don't-- but there's a certain
kind of-- when things just came
together.
Was there a time when
things just came together
and you knew you didn't
feel that anxiety, as such?
Was there a time?
I'm still looking for it.
In fact, I don't
ever want to find it.
Mm-hmm.
Because if you're not just
that little bit afraid
at the beginning of every film,
then you become complacent,
and there's no space for it.
We're incredibly privileged.
We're paid to make films.
And so with that privilege
comes a responsibility,
and that responsibility
is to make those films
as best as you possibly can.
And I believe that,
as a cinematographer,
the exploration of the
art of cinematography,
the art of filmmaking, the art
of storytelling never ends.
You never know everything,
and you should never
become complacent.
When did you know that you
wanted to be a cameraman?
When did you know that
you didn't want to direct,
when you knew you
didn't want to do sound?
I want to put this
thing on my eye
and I want to sort
of start shooting?
Was it the image?
Well, it wasn't that long ago.
For many years, through
circumstance more than desire--
you know, I always
thought I'd would
be a writer-director
when I was young,
and that's what I
was going to do.
How did you get to that point?
When did film catch you as well?
Well, I had been a news
cameraman for about 10 years,
and then I was a documentary
cameraman for about 10 years.
And I was getting kind of
bored with that format.
And very fortunately, I
got fired off of a job,
the only job I've ever been
fired off of, and took that
time and opportunity-- and I
was really very upset as well--
to go off to do a cinematography
seminar at the International
Film and Television
School of Rockport, Maine,
which was being given
by Billy Williams.
And I was there for a week.
And after the third day,
I suddenly thought, wow,
I actually--
I need to be a cinematographer.
Forget about writing.
Forget about directing.
I love this.
What was that thought?
Why did you need to be
a DP, cinematographer?
Why?
I don't know.
I think for so many
years I was in denial.
I loved being a cameraman.
And I had shot for so many
years, always in the belief
that I was going to
be something else.
And what Billy
Williams managed to do
was to put together a lot of
disparate things in my mind
about being a cameraman,
about being a cinematographer.
And things clicked, not
just technically, but also
emotionally, in a way
that was unexpected.
Was it story?
It must have been--
I'm thinking it might
have to be story.
I don't know.
Well, that was a very big part
of it, this sudden realization
that, OK, if you're
working in drama,
there are things that you
can do with the camera,
with the lighting,
with movement, with all
of the aspects of
cinematography that
tell the story in a different
way, because up to that point,
I had been reactive.
When you're doing
news documentaries,
you're simply reacting
to everything around you.
And suddenly, I was presented
with the possibility
of creation--
Mm-hmm.
Control.
--of the creation of images.
And that was just--
it was overpowering to suddenly
realize that, oh, my God, there
is actually
something to this job
that I had just been doing to
make money for all these years.
And then literally, from
the end of that week
on, that's all I wanted
to do, was to be--
What was it like, your first
day on set, on a film set,
on a motion picture film set?
What was that like,
the first day.
It was absolutely terrifying.
It was really--
I thought I was ready.
I thought I was really prepared.
And it was like, no, you're not.
It was was unlike anything
I'd ever done before.
But it was good terrifying.
It was just exciting and
challenging and unexpected.
And at the end of
it, it was like, OK,
I know what I'm going to be
doing for the rest of my life
now, so long as
they don't fire me.
Is there usually a
certain sense or feeling
you have when you read a
script for the first time
on how it could evolve?
What's the first reaction when
you go to read the script?
You think in images, or not?
Well, when I first
read a script,
I purposely don't have
any images in my head.
I'm purely interested
in the story.
Am I interested in the story?
Does the story move me?
And that's the single
most important thing.
Is there an emotion that
is elicited by that script?
If there's no emotion,
then it's kind of,
what's the point of this?
What is the average viewer
going to see in this?
So it really is the--
it is the story that, on
top of everything else,
is the predicator of whether
I'm interested in a film.
And then secondly
is the director
and what their ideas are about
the telling of this story,
because if they
don't have any ideas,
then where's the
story going to go?
It can't become anything more
than what's written on the page
without an idea.
So it's really getting--
again, having an
emotional response
to what the director is saying,
and listening very carefully
to what they have to say,
and thinking, and then
start to develop the
visual side of things,
because it's the interpretation.
It's trying to get into
the director's head--
not that I've ever really tried
to get into your head, Steve.
It would be much too--
You're welcome.
I've only got a little head.
I couldn't take it.
It couldn't work.
Excuse me?
But it's sort of just trying
to understand what the core is.
What's the point of this?
For sure.
And then from that point,
trying to then kind of eke out
all the ideas around it
to sort of start to build
an approach, a visual approach,
to the film, slowly but surely,
and working with the director,
looking at films, looking at
photographs.
You've sent me poems.
You've sent me photographic
books, books of Velasquez,
which I still have
and still go over.
All of these things start
to inform an approach.
And then it's sort of
bouncing those ideas back
to the director and getting
steerage, movement, and finding
which way the film
is going to go.
And like we say, you
get all these ideas.
You get an approach.
You get an idea.
You talk through,
hopefully, the key scenes
and have a very strong idea
of what's going to happen.
But then you sit there firmly in
the knowledge that on the day,
you can just throw it all away.
Absolutely.
A few questions-- again,
when you're on set--
what I very much admire about
cinematography in general
is it's a hard job.
It's a really-- because
you're on your action, cut.
From the beginning of
the day, end of day,
everyone's running
off with the DP.
How do you stay focused?
I'm fascinated.
How do you keep your
concentration 100% all the way
through the day?
How do you do that?
Or can you?
Well, I think it's practice
more than anything else.
I've had the advantage of
all those years of working
technically with a camera
and lighting and everything
else for so many years
that I don't really
have to think about
that, and so then I
can really focus
on what's happening
at that moment in time.
And that's the key, because
it's the only thing that matters
is that moment in time.
And that's why I
operate as well,
because it keeps my focus.
I did one TV series
where I didn't operate,
and I will never do that again.
I was bored to tears--
Oh, my god.
--and in the end, could care
less about what was going on.
So I think that's--
--a big part of it, is just
being there and being right
on the front edge of it, which
is also an amazing privilege
because you get to see
those performances,
and you're right there.
And it's like, whoa.
And that's a very
regenerative thing.
My question-- again, for people
who are interested in being
a cinematographer--
what is the aspect--
again, I always
start a question with "what."
But what is the
thing that you feel
that someone needs
to be as a DP,
or at least have a
sort of a sense of?
You have to have, I think,
a very inquisitive mind.
You really need to
want to know things,
because there's so much to
know as a cinematographer.
Forget about all
the technical stuff.
It's trying to understand
the story itself,
trying to understand your
relationship with the director,
with all the other
heads of department,
trying to understand your
relationship with the crew
and how to get the
best out of them.
You're forever trying to
understand what's going on.
And constantly, you're always
looking, always looking
and always thinking,
and trying to get better
the whole time, because it's one
of those jobs that never ends.
Every film you do, well, if
you don't learn something new,
then I think you're
doing it wrong,
because you should
be pushing yourself.
You should be pushing your crew.
Everyone around you should
be striving to always become
better at what they're doing.
So I think the important thing
is to have an inquisitive mind,
to have an open mind, and to
have no ego, because there's
just no space for that
in a cinematographer.
One-- actors, tell me about-- of
course, I think a lot of people
want to know about actors.
And you're looking at the
lens, through the lens.
And of course, director's
looking at whatever.
How do you work with actors?
Directors work with
actors, of course,
but you work with actors too.
How do you work with actors?
What's your thing?
It's a thing of immense respect.
I think another
big part of my job
is to ensure that the
actors have the space,
and also, through control of
my crew and everything else
I possibly can, that
there are no distractions.
When they come on to set,
people are respectful.
They're quiet.
Everything is organized.
We're ready to go so that they
have all the time they need
with you to find a
performance to begin with,
and then they are not
distracted once we
get into the actual
filming side of it.
So the respect thing is--
there are only two
things that I've ever
failed in terms of the
academic world, and one of them
was acting, and the other
one was theater lighting.
Of the British
academic world, yeah.
But I know I can't
do what they do.
And I am in awe
of what they do--
Absolutely.
--and the power
that they possess.
And so I feel beholden
to do my best to ensure
that they can do their best.
Mm-hmm.
The other question
I want to ask you
is people like the script
supervisor, relationship
with that person, the
relationship with the producers
and so forth.
What's your
relationship with the,
outside of your crew,
the other aspects,
elements of the production?
I think of myself as a
director-cinematographer.
And so my main focus of
attention is the director.
But also ancillary to
that, the script supervisor
is absolutely crucial.
Yes.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
We love them and we hate them.
Yeah, do not ever cross
the script supervisor.
But everyone, I think, it
is a matter of respect.
Yes.
It's people working
under very close quarters
in very stressful situation.
So you really have to be as nice
as you can, as much as you can,
so that you're trying
to keep that stress out.
I don't want to
stress my crew out,
because that'll stress
me out, and it'll
stress everyone else out.
So it's trying to be
calm the whole time, calm
and differential.
When you need to be firm,
then you're firm, but only
when you need to.
It's that respect
that one generates
that allows people to
focus, to concentrate,
to take themselves seriously,
to respect themselves
so they don't become sloppy.
And I think that reverberates
throughout the crew,
and it's what you've
obviously said
and I have actually felt on set.
One of the questions I want to
ask you as well is lighting.
For people who want to be
DPs, how difficult is that?
Again, it's one
of those things--
how do you learn about lighting?
You're of master of light.
How do you-- how--
shooting somebody, and
having to find a frame,
and then lighting.
Like, there's all these lights
and stuff, and how do I--
where would you start from?
What advice would
you give someone?
Well, people look at lighting
as if it were a black art.
But it's not.
You look around you--
the world is lit.
There's natural daylight.
There's moonlight.
And then there are all
the man-made lights
that we put around us.
Just spend a little
bit of time looking
at the light in every
room that you walk into.
And after a while, you
start to understand.
You'll start to see the light
and see what the light's doing.
And I think it was
20 years of walking
into rooms as a documentary
and news cameraman.
I walk into a room and I know
exactly what the dominant light
source is, what the color
temperature of that light
is as well, even if you can't
see the color temperature.
So it's experience.
It's like any skill.
But you start with one light.
And in a dark room with
a figure in front of you,
shine that light on it.
And then move that light around,
because it's actually not
about light.
It's about shadows.
And it's how you then
manipulate those shadows
to hide or reveal.
That's really the initial
key, is understanding that.
And a lot of it is
really basic portraiture
and being able to look
at a face and understand
how it's going to
take the light,
and then plan accordingly
for the whole of the film.
But it's like everything
that is a skill.
It is learned over time.
And it's learned
through trial and error
and big, big, big mistakes--
I mean, massive mistakes--
that you're never
going to forget
and you're never
going to do again.
No.
But if you're not trying to
learn, trying to push it,
trying to understand,
then you're
never going to make a mistake.
And if you never make a mistake,
then you're never going to grow
and you're never going
to truly understand.
It's only through,
I think, humiliation
in many ways that
we can move forward,
even our own self-humiliation,
where we do something wrong.
But I know a lot of
people, when they first
start with
cinematography, they're
absolutely so afraid
of making a mistake
that they don't do anything.
And you can't progress that way.
So it's kind of a
fundamental of learning.
But lighting is really just
look around you, and really
start to look.
How do you communicate with
your grips and your gaffers?
How does that work?
You've had some-- you've got
great relationships with yours.
How did they work?
How does that work?
Well, when I first
started, I'd never
worked with a grip or a gaffer.
I had no idea what they do.
You had no use for them.
I had no use for them, exactly.
And I would move lights and
I would do things and move
tripods on this
set and the other.
But I was very fortunate.
The people that I
first worked with
were really patient with me.
And they kind of explained
what their jobs were
and what my job was.
And because of that, I have--
again, it's about respect.
They have knowledge and
skills that I don't have.
So I can take an idea and
explain it to them technically,
because over time, again, that's
another skill you develop,
is the language of filmmaking.
And we all-- grips
have a grip language.
Lighting people have
a lighting language.
Camera people have a camera
language with its own phrases
and terms and equipments
and everything else.
So as the cinematographer,
you slowly
learn all of those
things so that you
can have those
conversations with people
and explain what's in
your head in a way.
Communication-- I mean, I should
have said this so much earlier.
Communication is
everything when it
comes to working with a crew,
with a director, with anybody.
You have to be
able to understand
what the other person is saying
before you can act upon it.
So it's important to
get that language.
I think you were
very clear about that
in other ways, communication
as far as respect and listening
and so forth and whatnot,
what the director wants,
and how you can interpret it.
One way or the other,
you are extremely clear.
What-- a young person,
yourself or whatever--
what advice would you give
them about wanting to be a DP,
or just wanting to be in film?
So the main piece of
advice I would give
is that anything is possible.
If you want to, if you
really want to be in film,
you can be in film.
It takes a focus, a
dedication, a real stick-to-it.
I got my first paying
job as a cameraman.
I was probably 19 years old.
I shot for 20-odd years.
I had my first feature
film at the age of 39.
Wow.
So it doesn't happen overnight.
And all that time,
I was learning,
learning the basic
skills that are required.
So the thing is, don't expect
it to happen overnight.
Just keep at it.
Keep working.
Keep learning.
Every job, learn something new.
And just keep building
your skill levels
so that when a
door opens for you,
you can boldly walk through
it and kind of fool people
into thinking that what you know
and create that opportunity.
But it is about
opportunity, and it's
making those opportunities.
And you can only make
those opportunities
by putting yourself in places
with the knowledge that
will allow you to take
advantage of those opportunities
when they're presented with you.
So I think the
thing I would say,
if you want to be a
cinematographer, then shoot.
Shoot, shoot, shoot.
Shoot.
That's your most basic skill.
Just keep doing that.
And look at everything you
shoot and be as critical
as you can about
every single shot.
And think, how can
I do this better?
And just to that day,
that's what I do.
Every single shot,
I'll look at it
and try and think, well,
how can this be better?
How can this be better?
But a lot of people
want to be in films.
But they don't know what
they want to do in films.
It's very unusual
for a young person
to even know what a
cinematographer is.
So even if you're in your middle
age, as I was heading towards,
it could still happen.
You just need the
desire and the drive,
and a big, big lot of luck
to get that first door open.
Well, also, you
make your own luck.
You make your own
luck, for sure.
And you have done on
multiple occasions.
Can you talk to us about art
direction, art directors,
and the collaboration with
you and art directors?
I have a photograph of you and
Adam Stockhausen somewhere,
the A team.
Yeah, when we did
Widows, that was amazing,
that collaboration.
And of course, we worked,
and you guys worked together
on 12 Years as well.
Tell me about your relationship
with art directors in general.
Well, it's absolutely crucial
to try to develop a relationship
with the art director.
They come on the job months
before the cinematographer
does.
So they have had an awful lot of
time already with the director.
So the good ones, they
know which direction
they're going in.
And they can help
you then in letting
you know what that
direction is initially.
So you get a lift up.
By the time you spend with
them, the closer to the film
you can become, because they're
already that much closer to it.
And then once you start to get
the feel of the film itself,
then the collaboration
comes in, because you're
able to then suggest
things as well.
And with the two of
you, in the same way
that you're working with the
director, you can have ideas.
And they will-- the
good ones will listen,
and then very politely say no.
And the others
won't listen at all.
But it is that
collaborative approach,
which makes it more exciting.
I would never--
I would never begin
to think that I could
do the job of an art director.
Cinematography is hard
enough, but the skills
you need as an art director
are astounding and so far out
of my ballpark.
But talking with
an art director--
I mean, composition is
one of the key elements
of cinematography.
And as the operator
of the camera,
I'm looking for
compositions within a set.
If there's nothing there to work
with, then I'm kind of lost.
All I've got is a face.
So it's always of
interest to understand
what the art
department are doing
and how they're going
to dress the set
and how the set is constructed,
because that then feeds back
into how the compositions
can work within that set.
So it's a crucial relationship.
Well, we have been
working together now--
we've known each other
as a working relationship
for 20 years.
I think it was 21 years-- no,
20 years ago this month, we
were in Johannesburg in a
mine called Western Deep
3 kilometers underground
with a Super 8 camera.
And our last collaboration
was Widows, a major feature
film on 35 millimeter.
I'm sorry, but
there you have it.
We've come a long way, Steve.
No, we have come a long way.
You've come a way long way.
But I feel that sort of--
with you, that sort of--
not with me necessarily,
but I'm just
talking about giving our
relationship an example,
from the six Super 8 to
35, major feature film,
really smart kind of stuff.
How you're talking
about things is
so tangible and
graspable because it
seems that you've
had a lot of faith
in yourself and in the process.
And it's like-- again,
maybe it's like fishing.
There's an element--
there's a huge element.
There's a chasm of trust.
And it's like, wow, I thought
there would be a bridge there,
but there's not,
but you're still
able to do what you want to do.
Where does that come from?
I always talk to you about -
Sean Bobbitt is a Tai Chi DP.
I always said that
somehow you use the wind
or use the elements which
are around and you--
I don't know what you do.
But there's a certain
sense of faith.
I don't know.
Maybe it's spiritual.
I don't know, but it's
how do you professionalize
that, I don't know.
How do you do that?
I don't know.
I'm so fortunate in
the opportunities
that I've been given.
I'm always grateful
for the opportunity.
I'm very grateful to have
worked with you, Steve.
Western Deep changed
me for life--
some of it good, some
of the not so good.
[INAUDIBLE]
Claustrophobia, oh, my God.
Yikes.
But anyway, it opened
up inside of me
a possibility that I didn't know
existed, which was just that I
could be associated with art.
And see, guys?
You can do anything,
even with a Picso camera.
So forget your fancy camera.
You can do anything.
Yeah.
I want to address the questions
that came from the students,
because there's a few of them.
They're keen, and they want
to ask you, Sean Bobbitt,
the legend, questions.
So the first question is, how
can I learn cinematography
without a professional camera?
OK, this is a really
good question.
And it's one that I hope
everyone takes to heart.
A camera is simply a light-tight
box with an aperture for a lens
and a means of
recording the image.
That's it.
It doesn't do and
shouldn't do anything else.
You should be in charge of
what goes through that lens
into the camera.
People get caught
up in this idea
that if you get
better camera, you'll
be a better cinematographer.
It's not true.
It's complete-- it takes
you down a wrong road,
so far down a wrong road,
that it's something that I
constantly wish to dispel.
You can make a great movie--
you can tell a great story--
on an iPhone.
You can tell a story on
whatever type of camera
you have in front of you.
It's important if you want to
be a working cinematographer
in this huge industry,
you need to understand
the basics of photography.
Now, cinematographer,
photography is part of it.
"Cinema" is "motion." it's
ancient Greek for "motion."
so you are working
with moving images.
So once you learn
basic photography,
you then have to transpose
that into the movement,
so that instead of
taking a single shot,
you're working with a series
of shots to create a sequence.
Now, if you don't know
basic photography,
then you will never get beyond
that really basic level.
The problem with
most of the cameras
today is that they try
to do too much for you.
If you turn on auto-focus, if
you turn on auto-iris, if you
turn on auto-white
balance, the camera's
making all those decisions.
Those are the decisions that
you as a cinematographer
have to make to
create the image.
So turn all that stuff off.
You need to be in control of
the camera, not the camera
in control of you.
A really high-spec,
professional camera,
for the cinematographer, it
simply has an on/off button.
And that's it.
There are no bells and
whistles, no frills.
Everything else is down
to you and your crew
to use the camera to create the
image that you want to create.
But you can't do that
until you understand
the fundamentals of photography,
lighting, and camera movement.
That moves into the
second question, really.
The question is, what is your
favorite camera and lenses
to use on set, and why?
Yeah, now I'm just going
to blow it completely.
Exactly.
No, my favorite camera
to use on the film
is the camera that's
correct for that project.
These days, you have
an immense choice
between film cameras, Super 8,
Super 16, 35 mil still, 65 mil.
Plus you've got all
the digital formats.
As a cinematographer,
you've never
had such a choice ever in the
history of cinematography.
And you have lenses, thousands
of different types of lenses.
And the lens is actually more
important than the camera
because that's what
creates the image.
The camera just records it.
The lens, that's the key.
So I will choose
the camera and I
will choose the lens in
relation to what the story is.
For example, 12
Years a Slave, that
had to be shot on 35 mil and
a modern 35 mil film stock,
for a whole bunch of
different reasons.
And part of it was
just the contrast ratio
that's inherent
in 35 mil film, so
that we can have darker flesh
tones and lighter flesh tones
in the same frame without having
to light them individually,
so that you can
maintain a reality.
But it also-- film, because
of the grain structure,
it has a sense of period
to it automatically.
So we didn't have to screw
around with things visually
to create that sense of period.
Most of that done was
by the art design.
But also, subconsciously,
we could induce a past
by the introduction of the
grain of the film itself.
For this last film I did,
Judas and the Black Messiah,
it was similar sort of thing.
It's a historical, a
true, historical story.
But given the
location we were at
and various other
financial considerations,
we had to shoot it digitally.
And so my choice was the
ALEXA LF, the ARRI ALEXA LF,
large-format camera with
the ARRI DNA lenses--
large format because, again,
it had that extended contrast
ratio for darker and
lighter flesh tones,
and the DNA lenses because
the kind of anamorphic look
to them, although
they're spherical.
So again, you get
that period feel,
but it's a subconscious thing.
It's not in your face.
So for example, going
down in Western Deep,
Super 8, little cassettes--
why?
Because it was the
only camera that we
could take in terms of safety,
but also in terms of size
and ease of use.
So the camera, you
choose what works.
OK.
The next question
is-- and I think
it relates to what you just
said before-- which film
or films in your
career helped you
to find your voice
as a cinematographer?
What did you learn
from those experiences?
I think you answered
that question, no?
Yeah, and every film
informs every other film
that you ever do.
For an actor, the
image is everything.
So what is the cinematographer's
relationship with the actors
like?
Well, again, as I said
before, it's respect.
But there's also one
other very crucial thing
to be aware of as a
cinematographer, and especially
if you're an operator.
If you're there with
the actors and you're
right up next to them, the
director is some distance away.
So at the end of every scene,
the actors look at you first.
They do.
And you cannot
interact with them.
You must never get in the
way in between an actor
and a director.
You don't give direction.
You don't tell them
it's good or it's bad.
I just smile like an idiot
and kind of nod my head
and turn around and walk
away, because that's not
my job to get involved.
And if you do start
to get involved,
that is a very rocky road
that's going to lead to tears.
Thanks.
Yeah.
Well, I have said--
I have actually said,
Sean, what do you think?
At times, yeah.
That-- it's allowed.
And I'll always have an opinion.
Yes, and thank God.
Thank God for it.
The last question--
Lupita Nyong'o is admired
and highly respected by young
people in Kenya and
in the refugee camps.
What was it like
to work with her?
What is she like as
an artist on set?
And I was aware of
the incredible journey
you'd been on to find
just the right person.
And so I was really intrigued
as to who this person was.
And there is a focus
and a calmness to her.
And I've had the pleasure
of working with her again
on Queen of Katwe.
And it is boom.
When she comes on to
set, she's ready to go.
She knows her stuff.
She's done all the work.
And it's really-- it's always
a pleasure just to watch,
because there is stuff that's
going to happen there that you
never expected to find.
And there's such a
professionalism as well.
And in terms of the
relationship with the director,
with everyone else, she's
a fantastic role model--
And she was--
--for anyone who's interested
in getting into cinema.
She was a star,
for sure, because I
think it was her star
that shined brightly,
but it was one of
those things where
she was right for
the role, but also
right for the moment, and
her speeches at that time,
and when we're hearing
about people's skin
color in the press today.
And I remember Lupita
giving this amazing speech.
I think it was at the--
it was the Essence Awards
when she talked about her skin
color, being so dark and
how she wanted to be light.
And it was just--
she was just amazing.
That's a star.
OK, that was the last
question from the students.
And thank you very much
for those questions.
And Sean, it's a
pleasure knowing you,
an honor knowing you.
You are an artist.
I'll say it again.
If you didn't know
it-- better you
don't know it so your
head doesn't get that big.
But--
I still don't believe
you, but it's nice of you.
Well, regardless.
OK, well, trust me.
But you're an artist
and an amazing DP.
And I just want to say thank
you for all of your amazing work
through working with all
these directors and the images
you've made.
And Judas and the Black Messiah
is an amazing piece of work,
so congratulations on that.
And thank you very
much, everyone,
for tuning into this
conversation with Sean Bobbitt.
Sean, thank you.
And everyone else, good night.
Take care.
Bye bye.
Thank you, Steve.
It's been a real pleasure.